ce soir c'est la fête de l'amour c'est
la fête de la saint valentin et on a mis
un principe de l'offre cannes c'est très
simple c'est dans le public vous allez
voir dès que vous allez entendre
ce sont d'ailleurs bon leur temps il ya
une large gamme qui va se balader et
elle va s'arrêter sur une personne dans
le public regardez c'est la grue d'abba
elle devra faire une déclaration d'amour
à une autre personne
d'accord attention c'est parti d'une
gueule
[Applaudissements]
sur ces deux personnes vale moi j'ai
envie d'aller me rejoindre alors venez
là vous allez nous dire comment vous
appelez bonsoir voit sa fin ce soir
comment vous appelez on line et mauline
et vous voici sébastien emeline certes
vous êtes ensemble oui vous êtes mariés
non non vous êtes ensemble depuis
maintenant 15 ans et vous vous dites
combien c'est toujours comme ça il ya
toujours un problème en fait entre la
durée il ya toujours le mec qui dit
qu'il est resté moins de temps avec la
meuf
c'est beau vous êtes là tous les deux
pour la saint valentin c'est votre
cadeau de saint valentin
oui de venir me voir oui ah oui bah ça
me fait plaisir tout fait un bisou mais
merci merci beaucoup font un gros bisou
aussi alors je crois qu'on vous a pas
choisi par hasard
emeline c'est lui qui vous a dit de
venir aujourd'hui c'est vous ouais c'est
vous oui parce que je crois qu'il a une
déclaration à vous faire ce soir c'est
vous oui merci merci olivier abidal qui
dors mon loulou ya maintenant 17 ans aux
chemins se sont croisés pas vraiment par
hasard car c'est mon frère qui nous a
présenté aujourd'hui n'est plus là pour
voir ce que je suis en train de faire
mais je suis sûr qu doit être fier de ce
que nous sommes devenus depuis toutes
ces années
tu es mon adoré celui que je chérirai
oui je n'ai pas peur de le dire jusqu'à
la fin 2010 je ne te le dit pas assez
souvent mais je suis fier de toi je suis
fier d'être t'accompagner dans les bons
comme dans les mauvais moments
je suis aussi très fier d'eux parce que
tu portes la famille à bout de bras et
je que je pourrai toujours compter sur
toi tu me l'a déjà prouvé par le passé
et même encore aujourd'hui grâce à toi
je suis maman de trois merveilleuses
fille et un jour je sais on portera le
même nom de famille en fête
il l'aura compris si je suis là
aujourd'hui devant toi c'est tout
simplement pour te dire sébastien je
t'aime à l'infini et pour la visite
certes
sébastien je me sens très ému ouais
alors les chérit les chéris emeline si
je t'avais un petit peu pieri parce que
hamlin
je sais que tu étais venu faire une
déclaration d'amour à sébastien mais
nous ce soir il ya marianne et les ânes
qui sont là et qui voudrait te dire
quelque chose
marianne et les ânes qui sont là alors
vous avez quel âge les filles 14 ans 14h
et war vite en huit ans alors les chéris
vous voulez parler à maman ce soir elle
n'était pas du tout au courant vous êtes
vous avez des micros d'autres très bons
déjà des fleurs c'est pour maman c'est
vrai que c'est pas pour moi non pas du
tout il faut pas les lâcher
allez-y béchir et je crois que vous avez
quelque chose avait créé quelque chose
pour pauvre maman que j'aime merci pour
tout ce que tu fais pour nous trois
chaque jour tu nous porte un amour de
plus en plus fort même si on n'a pas
toujours ce qu'on veut on sait que tu
fais de ton mieux on t'aime maman
certes des fois il y a des hauts et des
bas mais il faut rester fort elle se
battre jusqu'au bout
tu verras la vie n'a pas rendu son
dernier souffle et nous n'avons pas fini
de te rendre heureuse tu t'occupes
tellement bien de nous que tu n'as même
pas une seconde pour toi et pour ça
j'aimerais tous remercié du fond de mon
coeur
mais pas qu'ils savaient pas on a eu
énormément de chance de t'avoir je
t'aime tout qu'est-ce que tout au monde
ma maman cher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pensais à ton âge n'aurait jamais
fait ça c'est très courageux de sa part
il ses trois changements
les chéris je sais que emeline elle
n'arrête pas que la journée s occupe
beaucoup de vous c'est une maman
formidable et j'aimerais que tu
t'occupes un peu tôt hamlin parce que
c'est ce que tu m'as dit avant vie voilà
deux qui fait aussi et alors tu es très
jolie voix là et tu vas pouvoir faire un
nom de spa coiffure massage manucure
[Applaudissements]
également je sais que sébastien
travaille énormément
ça fait quinze ans que vous n'avez pas
faire un kiff de vacances tous ensemble
et bien les chéris je vous offre un
voyage au maroc dans un autre
bakou
voilà joue fortement les chéris
les petits bien sûr les mutants cadeaux
et j'ai pu me plein de cadeaux regardez
c'est pour vous bien entendu voilà où on
embauche
voilà c'est la grande voilà la grande
[Applaudissements]
marée noire de monde merci des séries
merci mon bébé et compte en tirer
quelques jours que papa et maman il part
ils partent en vacances un têtu va être
content je te fais un gros bisou c'est
un amour je voudrais dire merci d'avoir
est avec nous merci bastien je te fais
des normes bisous et voilà vous êtes une
belle famille et profiter et je vous
fais un énorme bisou merci
[Applaudissements]